I'm told you're into knitting yes I'm
really into knitting so my character so
just the show is really dark and it was
like get out of the headspace what's the
opposite of Jessica Jones knitting
knitting sure so I got really into
knitting and I even like designed a line
of knitting kids for we are knitters and
it's just me I really got into and as a
thank you we are knitters really yeah
what's called we are knitters it's
awesome I think the Urban Outfitters for
knitting okay but as a thank you for
writing my speech I made you a hat you
made me a hat really did you seriously
I've I've made my cards this is
fantastic
[Applause]
you can fold that I know I could fold it
but I like this this this giant I like
it being as tall as possible I look like
a piece that you move around a board you
look like a Halloween Secret Santa yeah
it's I can't believe you made this
yourself
so you think yeah ho ho that's gonna be
cooler yeah no one's gonna recognize and
then I want to mention this because this
is very impressive you wrote a novel and
it's called bonfire and I don't know
where you got the time to do this it
took it took a few years what made you
get the gumption to say okay I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna write a novel well it
was something that I was developing
already as a TV pilot and then my agent
said it maybe wouldn't sell unless it's
easier to sell things that are existing
intellectual property right so I was
like all right well let me just try to
do that instead right and kind of think
outside the box and pay my own way and I
spent years writing it very cool
that's very impressive and so are you
gonna do write another one yeah well
yeah yeah I hope so
yeah I love doing and I love the process
it takes a long time yeah sometimes it's
paralyzing how much work it is right but
I hope yeah I just it's so crazy to me
that you're writing the and you're also
cranking out and cranking out hats for
people like me all right well we have a
clip from Jessica Jones I want to make
sure that we get to anything we need to
know about this I think you've been
you're being detained yeah it's a scene
with myself and carrie anne moss and i
find myself on the wrong side of the law
yeah let's take a look at this clip from
jessica jones what am i even still doing
in here it's been 24 hours the police
have 72 hours before they have to charge
you Trisha already gave a statement they
have no proof they believe that you know
that you're not telling them yeah it's
called professional discretion well they
will call it obstruction of justice
it's a probation violation [ __ ] and
that'll put me away for 18 months unless
you tell them what you know
a poodle doesn't show its belly to a pit
bull if it doesn't want to get its guts
ripped out and you're the poodle or they
will lump me in with that maniac and
they will start pinning every unsolved
crime on me because that's what they do
mmm not that you have a chip on your
shoulder just fix this very cool the new
season of Marvel's Jessica Jones
streaming now on netflix Kristin's book
bonfire is available right now and this
hat is mine you can't have this hat it's
only for me Krysten Ritter thank you so
much for being here
[Applause]
you